so if i've read this correctly that
with mission park you were initially
given the script a few years ago
and you were auditioning for one role
and somehow you now
are
still in it as an actor i believe agent
ortiz but you're the producer now how
did that all transpire i was actually
working on another film in san antonio
as an actor
and brian ramirez the writer director of
mission park crashed
the uh wrap party because he came with
someone who he knew was involved in the
production yeah
you know we latinos we crash a lot of
parties so he crashed the party
and uh
it's a small community
in terms of the filmmakers there so
he knew that i was there and i had
already
at the time had been brothers
on my resume and
resurrection boulevard and starmap so he
was well aware of my career
and he came up to me and said hey man i
wrote a script as many people always do
and
his pitch was different
he's like nicholas gonzalez who worked
with me on resurrection boulevard
nicholas gonzalez read it and loved it
that was his pitch to me
so i was like all right well if nicholas
loved it i'll check it out so he gave it
to me he's like yeah let me know what
role you like and i read it it took me a
while
to get to it because i was busy at the
time and i i just uh i'm slow at getting
to scripts it's a bad habit of mine i'm
just
so but when i finally did open up the
script and
read it i went straight through it was
just an easy read and i really enjoyed
it and i loved the characters um
backstory i thought they were phenomenal
and just seeing these kids and and
seeing what happens
when
characters make choices and why
like their history really propels these
choices i believe or initiates these
choices
and that's what connected me to the
story and one of the characters i loved
the most was derek
so when i called ryan i said i loved
your script and i really loved this role
he wasn't the lead character
uh it was sort of one of the leads um
and that's the one i connected with the
most
and so i gave him an loi letter of
interest
so that he could go around pitching
to investors that i was attached along
with walter perez who was the first
actor to ever get a hold of that script
outside of nicholas gonzalez who's from
san antonio texas
so
here we had two actors and one director
attached to this project
and i said call me when you you know you
have the money i'm down
um
it just sat around for a while until
jeremy ray valdez called me he had
achieved success at sundance with la
michiong
and said
he said that there were investors
interested in funding his career you
know investing in another project of his
if he had one so he called me i sent him
mission park he fell in love with it
and he was perfect for bobby and that's
the role he connected with so now we had
three actors and one director
brian needed a producer
that's what this project needed
directors and actors
you know
aren't really the ones to make this
happen producers are they really get
behind it they they put everything
together and package
the project
and that's what brian needed at the time
i had already done about three or four
short films that i produced and directed
so
i was like thinking in the back of my
head that
i was ready for a feature
and i felt that i could be the producer
for brian that i wanted for myself when
i was directing these short films
i felt that i could be that producer
and
so we had a conversation about it i said
look you need a producer i've produced a
couple short films i think i can do this
film
and also i i want you to
achieve your vision
and not have hollywood alter that
you know because they will
and he said sure we agreed to it and i
took it and ran with it and
now i'm running all the way to september
5th
which is our opening day
theatrical release so we're excited